you've got on David Beckham you've got
met your match I just wanted to meet you
first time in my life I realized I
totally enough to love one person
it wasn't a pun
wasn't the person standing next to me
nope why is yours not in a champagne
glass q you want people to think I'm
just a man of the people a simple white
wine from me I just like drinking more
than anyone else at one time let's get
started yeah two
we did
Oh
who would you say is your favorite spice
girl I'm a Bunton Baby Spice she's your
favorite she's my fan who's next
Oh to that just a question all of the
other four so ever Bunton well Emma
Bunton was the one that I had blonde
hair and bangs and my name obviously is
now Emma my name was Emily but it was
taken when I became an actor um and so
now with Emma and uh yeah I just I love
so get me this so you won gave you a
video message and one talked to you on
skype yes but are you telling me you've
never met I use watching anything
something have you never said what do
you mean to be something really have you
never met a Spice Girl I'm wait hold on
have you never met a Spice Girl riding
the flash okay now hello as you know
I'm up he's very rare it is very rare
for more than one Spice Girl to appear
together
for any reason at all so they're not
here
Oh
but it's it's just there's something I
don't know something about it makes me
want to kind of do
don't take it there think I'm a cute
Ulta
very good
we don't know who is going to next oh oh
yeah
I'll take that card
but Aaron Paul you must be so bored of
this
my advice to you is to buy this footage
so it never gets seen again cuz have you
seen it you must have seen this footage
umpteen time
what what what footage oh you do know oh
I think I know what you're talking
intent it because it's so fascinated
well we haven't seen I'm sure it's been
shown a lot the state my hand I haven't
seen it before right this is a very
young Aaron Paul on The Price is Right
some of my finest work this is yeah
who's our next player well let's see
what can do for erina Sturdevant come on
price is right
here the band
amazing
now
we were going to have a you wanted a
tattoo on your penis is that right
but you thought it might be too sore I
don't know that one I wanted to put a
tattoo if I would get one there that
would say buyer beware what are you
gonna say hey I'm impressed as enough
room I tell you Wow and I can assure you
he knows there is I've met the Trump at
all things Jennifer I haven't no I was
at a concert and I heard he was
attending so I had my full security like
I was like fine Donald Trump cuz I was
just I was adamant on finding him and
then making a video of me going hey
Trump
[__] you droplet look at your fear what
are you afraid of well I was gonna go
with flying but I think I'll go with
girls over 12
so I want to say I like a Swilly sky
yes they did like like Michael cheat on
me when was in a beef heart because he's
telling me he's I you know unless you or
whatever miss me one want by your mother
you had a French girlfriend didn't you
that's right yeah
amazing I know you keen on the French
flavors I was 22 at the time 23 yes she
taught me a lot I mean amazing and it's
uh you know it's it's difficult down
there I'm gonna be polite and sort of
you know very your screen the same time
just say what do you want well funny
started there very hairy so they don't
do bikini waxes in France
I went home one weekend I was in my 30s
I was probably 33 years of age I went
home to see my mother and then I went
back and while I was at home my mother
did my washing for me because I was only
33 and I went back on the on the Sunday
night I got really drunk and then I went
for a curry and then the next day I went
into school I'm going to I went into
school and it was a school in Slough and
it was quite a rough school but they had
a really brilliant hearing-impaired
Department so they were hearing impaired
kids who you know struggled they were
they were really looked after in the
school anyway I was really hungover I
went there and I bet break time I felt
really uncomfortable I thought
something's not right you know so I went
to the toilet and I pulled my trousers
down and some of my mother's knickers
got I've got mixed up in the washing and
I was wearing my mother's
Oh gone now I remember they are you lose
and this is such a low point you [__]
loser
and then the Korean food the Korean the
booze kicked in from the night before
so I I have I did like a fecal Jackson
Pollock and I say that's a guy ah God
not this now this as well
oh Jesus so I clean myself up and I
pulled my mother's pants back I went
back into the classroom and I saw one of
the hearing impaired kids looking at me
like this and that's when I remembered
that my I had a microphone directly
like a power
I could feel the mist every time we kiss
just didn't know it down for like this
desert there's a flash-forward warning
will it will rain in the morning and
they'll be puddles in the bed I wanna
get to want you to push it
let's get
the legs
who should give
maybe walks in and she steps right him
she steps right in my pee pajamas and
and this is what
that's wrong well don't don't touch the
man they're guessing you don't sugarcoat
things do you get stars talking to me
Michael I do sometimes I do sometimes I
remember when I was young I and I met
Laurence Olivier
well that was I used to collect
autographs at the stage door no and he
came out and I remember so distinctly
that I started to cream in my knickers
Oh
your grace
well you can you appear to be done on
the one side
so science
so to you on the show
david beckham you've gone off met your
match
Oh